what's going on guys this is Rob and the
trailer for Blue Beetle came out and it
looks amazing so we're gonna cover the
origin story of Jaime Reyes in DC Comics
so what this does is this initially
picks up on reach world with a race
called The Reach now the reach is an
incredibly old race and in fact they're
the second oldest race in DC Comics the
only race older than them are the
maltuzians also known as the Owens the
Guardians of the universe basically the
group that created the Green Lanterns
now there is a non-aggression pact
between the reach and the Owens in the
sense that the reach while they do
operate on a world they can't
necessarily engage in like acts of War
but the reality and really the
development behind the entirety of the
Blue Beetle Scarab is basically an act
of War so the overall goal here of the
reach is pretty genius what they did is
they designed this Scarab for the
purpose of traveling to any world that's
out there and then bonding itself to the
dominant life force not only that but as
far as the dominant life force went the
Scarab would Bond itself to the most
capable member of the dominant life
force so say for example that the Scarab
showed up on Earth under any normal
circumstance it would Bond itself to
Superman because Superman is arguably
the most powerful being on Earth there's
debate there right there's like Martian
Manhunter Black Adam during World War
III when he basically killed the DC
Universe there's a link to that video in
the description in case you're curious
about it but there's all kinds of
different characters who are really
powerful but the overall gist here and
really the reason why the Blue Beetle
does not Bond itself to Superman when it
gets to Earth is something that we'll
explain here but it's kind of a field
test what the Blue Beetle does or at
least what the reach do is they send the
Scarab out into space and then it
basically bonds itself to a little girl
that exists on this planet now the
planet itself is kind of a loose term
it's really more just kind of a space
station that makes its way through the
universe but when it bonds itself to the
little girl one of the things that ends
up happening is she basically uses her
powers over what's called dark force
energy or dark energy basically magic in
a more traditional sense and then in
turn because she's so capable the
intention is to basically take over the
entirety of the world conquer it and
then bring it under the control of the
reach it's a way for them to
unofficially expand their empire because
to any anybody else out there who's
watching the events unfold they would
just see it as this little girl went
crazy and then conquered the entirety of
her people and killed most everybody
because the nature of the Scarab is that
it secretly influences and controls its
own host now the crazy thing about this
is that the Scarab itself quite
literally says this girl is an anomaly
right like being bonded to her will not
work just because of the level of power
that she has and in fact the Scarab says
all of my power was redirected to a new
objective Escape simply because of the
fact that when this Scarab tries to bond
with her and the girl initially rejects
it she uses her power to try to tear the
Scarab apart if for no other reason than
the fact that she's just insane quite
literally when you first see her she's
playing with like a little doll and
she's talking about how like the dolls
can't touch each other like that
otherwise they'll be punished and then
she tears it apart so like this girl's
got problems but the Scarab ultimately
just takes off and Retreats as fast as
it can now once the Scarab gets away we
do spend a moment or two with this
little girl all this really told to us
is that she will at some point become
lady sticks but to the confines of this
particular story she's not overly
important but what ends up happening is
that when the scare basically bails out
and tries to get back to reach what ends
up happening is that because the race
had made enemies specifically because of
the fact that the Owens had learned that
the reach were engaging in Acts of War
subterfuge and basically violating the
non-aggression treaty the Green Lanterns
responded and so one of the lanterns
goes after the Scarab and in response
the Scarab basically panics due to the
fact that its systems are still
suffering as a result of its experience
with a little girl it opens a portal and
just takes off and that's when it
basically arrives on Earth in the
Yucatan Peninsula in the very early days
of humanity and so once a crash lands
here literally just down in South
America that there is a tribe that does
Discover it and when that happened the
leader of the tribe ends up bonding with
the Scarab and when it does he becomes
the first Blue Beetle on earth now one
of the big differences here is that
where the Scarab was initially created
for the purpose of taking over the host
controlling the host and then destroying
the world and making the world ready for
the reach to invade because of his
experience with a little girl because of
the conflict with the Green Lantern the
scare was basically damaged and so what
it does is it imbues its host with
powers but it can't control the host and
so it's just kind of left to the host to
decide how those Powers get used now
what we end up learning is that this
group that is now in possession of the
the Blue Beetle Scarab these are the
Mayans and the Mayans themselves have
been chased off their own land by the
nahua people I'm pretty sure that's how
it's pronounced I I apologize if I've
totally butchered it but with the Blue
Beetle in their possession the Mayans
end up taking their own land back and
this is really interesting the way that
is said right it's stated in a matter of
weeks the nahuwa were chased far from
Maya Lance the survivors took refuge in
a marsh where Mexico City stands today
if Sky witness which is the name given
to the guy who has a Blue Beetle Scarab
if Sky witness had not spared them the
nahuwa would never have established the
Aztec empire but even when they regained
their might the Aztecs remembered their
old Foe and Sky witness lived on now
we're also told Sky witness ruled over
the Maya for over 100 100 prosperous
Earth years but in time my Med systems
could no longer prolong his life again
this monologue coming from the Blue
Beetle Scarab itself and so in response
to this the sky witness ends up going to
his son and were initially his son
believed that the Scarab would be passed
down from one generation to the next the
reality of the sky witness is twofold
first he realizes the level of power
that he has and that power is Coveted
and so if someone who was a nefarious
were to get their hands on the Scarab
there's no telling what could happen any
number of things could lead to this too
an assassination a thief sneaking in in
the middle of the night a member of
their own tribe betraying them right
this could happen in a variety of ways
the other thing that's going on here is
he says it speaks to me my son it wants
a new man to empower but I know it only
seeks a weaker mind to control I cannot
allow this and where his son asks how
can I help he says just keep our people
away from this pyramid let no one seek
to recover its treasures and when the
son asks what Treasures the response
months and really the only response the
father gives him is go my son you will
understand when I am gone and what the
father does is he literally crashes down
the entirety of the pyramid now the
Scarab tries to escape it literally
tries to flee but the the sky witness is
able to Siege the Scarab and they're
both buried alive together and so what
we're told is that over the years that
the Scarab just kind of became a thing
that no one really knew about right if
anything it was maybe a rumor that
people had discussed or kind of a legend
but the reality here is that it just
fell out of all knowledge and so the
result to this is that it's ultimately
discovered by a treasure hunter the
treasure hunter in turn sells it and
it's by that way that the Scarab travels
from one hand to the next going from one
place to the other now this is where uh
ladama comes into play because one of
the things that we learn here is that
she is a person who is on the hunt for
the Scarab now as far as I'm aware DC
plays it pretty fast and loose with the
idea that like ladama will become lady
sticks because it is an alias that she
used at some point along the line again
I'm not hugely familiar with the Blue
Beetle Mythos but the the important
thing and the important take away from
this is that Jaime Reyes was actually
caught in the conflict like literally
caught in the crossfire between ladama
trying to get her hands on the Scarab
and other people who were trying to stop
her the result of this is that it ends
up bonding itself to Jaime Reyes and
that's how Jaime Reyes ended up becoming
the Blue Beetle but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end hopefully this uh origin story gets
you caught up on the character let me
know if you want to learn more about him
and I will catch you all later peace